fest steht dass es im weltraum deutlich
mehr materie als antimaterie gibt doch
das rätselraten ist groß warum in aller
welt existiert dieses ungleichgewicht
vollkommen unlogisch wie lässt sich die
dominanz der materie im universum
erklären
am genfer kernforschungszentrum cern ist
man genau dieser frage einen schritt
näher gekommen oder der antwort und hat
jetzt mit super aufwändigen analysen von
teilchen zerfallen eine teillösung parat
also was ist da rausgekommen klicks und
science fiction abonniert den kanal
denn hier gibt es täglich spannende
science videos herzlich willkommen schon
seit knapp 90 jahren wissen wir dass
jedes teilchen einen partner hat ein
antiteilchen beim elektronen ist es zum
beispiel das positron doch wenn wir weit
zurückschauen wird nicht nur deutlich
wie wenig wir bisher über materie und
antimaterie wissen sondern auch wie
wichtig das zusammenspiel von materie
und antimaterie ist denn beim urknall
vor 13,7 jahren entstand heutiger
vorstellungen zufolge eigentlich genauso
viel antimaterie wie materie
all diese teilchen im jungen kosmos
prallten auf entgegengesetzt gepolte
antiteilchen doch warum haben sich
antimaterie und materie nicht sofort
wieder vollständig vernichtet so wie es
doch eigentlich immer der fall ist wenn
antiteilchen und teilchen aufeinander
treffen
die antwort darauf wissen wir bis heute
nicht doch klar ist das ganze war wohl
eine art kosmischer fügung denn aus den
übrig gebliebenen bruchteil von materie
bildeten sich im laufe von milliarden
jahren sterne planeten und galaxien
astronomie teams weltweit gehen davon
aus dass ein subtiler unterschied
zwischen materie und antimaterie dafür
gesorgt hat dass ein teil der materie
überlebt hat doch worin genau liegt
dieser unterschied warum gibt es dieses
ungleichgewicht im universum warum wir
stehen sterne planeten und menschen fast
ausschließlich aus materie und warum ist
die antimaterie gegen solch ein exot
welche subatomaren prozesse im urknall
haben etwas mehr materie als antimaterie
hervorgebracht fragen über fragen auf
die wir bis heute keine endgültigen
antworten wissen experten und
expertinnen vermuten dass ein gewisser
effekt der etwas mit der symmetrie zu
tun also dem gleichgewicht oder eben
nicht gleichgewicht von materie
antimaterie zu tun hat die antwort auf
diese frage sein könnte ein mechanismus
der symmetrie verletzung der alle
elementarteilchen betrifft die aus einem
quark und einem antrag bestehen also
schon seit längerer zeit wird vermutet
naturgesetze behandeln materie und
antimaterie nicht gleichwertig schon vor
längerer zeit wurde bei den sogenannten
k und b mesonen einen unterschied
festgestellt missionen bestehen aus
insgesamt sechs quarks orten und sind ab
und an auch aus kanti quax aufgebaut
experimente in den 60er jahren hatten
gezeigt dass der zerfall von personen
aus antiques nicht exakt symmetrisch zum
zerfall der materie variante der carlson
abläuft heißt also vereinfacht
physikalische prozesse ändern sich wenn
die ladung c vertauscht wird also zieht
charts und teilchen durch ihre
antiteilchen ersetzt werden zudem ändern
sich die physikalischen prozesse wenn
sie spiegelverkehrt also die parität p
betrachtet wird das heißt es gibt ebenso
eine veränderung bei der änderung des
spins der drehrichtung von
elementarteilchen das phänomen bei dem
die sogenannte cp symmetrie verletzt
wird wird in der fachsprache auch als zb
verletzung bezeichnet das c steht dabei
wie gesagt für charge also ladung und
das p für parity also parität in der
physik heißt dann so viel wie die
symmetrie eigenschaft eines systems
gegenüber seiner räumlichen spiegelungen
das übrigens auch die b mesonen die cp
symmetrie verletzten ist seit anfang der
2000er jahren bekannt der zerfall dieser
b mesonen im experiment lieferte ebenso
wie der zerfall der kommission einen
überschuss an materie
doch beide waren viel zu klein um die
dominanz der materie im universum zu
erklären jetzt ist es ein physik team
vom genfer kernforschungszentrum cern
gelungen ein weiteres puzzlestück in
diesem zusammenhang aufzudecken
konkret hatten die wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler die zerr fälle
sogenannter den 0 millionen im auge
diese teilchen bestehen aus einem charme
und einem anti ab quark und wurden vor
40 jahren aufgespürt im large hadron
collider hatte man die d0 missionen und
ihre gegenstücke in den vergangenen
jahren in großer menge produziert doch
die teilchen sind äußerst kurzlebig und
zerfielen
schnell wieder in andere partikel so
entstand in den jahren zwischen 2011 und
2018 ein riesiger datenberg um an ein
ergebnis zu kommen mussten die lhc
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
die entstandenen produkte zählen dabei
kam heraus dass die anti demission
schneller zerfallen als ihre materie
bonbons die wohl deutlich stabiler sind
heißt also im klartext auch ihr
verletzten die zelle der ungeladenen 0
millionen die symmetrie regelt das cern
forschungsteam schlussfolgert aus diesem
ergebnis dass solche symmetrie
verletzten prozesse eben auch im frühen
universum eine schlüsselrolle gespielt
haben müssen
dies könnte dann auch dafür gesorgt
haben dass eben nicht die ganze materie
vernichtet wurde das ergebnis vom cern
kann zusammen mit dem bereits bekannten
unterschieden tatsächlich ein teil der
materie dominanz im universum erklären
da auch der nun gemessen effekt ist
längst nicht ausreichend um das
komplette übergewicht zu verstehen dafür
ist immer noch eine deutlich größere
verletzung der cp symmetrie notwendig
als man in experimenten bislang
beobachten konnte was aber wirklich
frappierend ist dass hier in immer mehr
fällen diese ungleichheit zwischen
materie und antimaterie festgestellt
wird nun setzen die fachleute auf die
erzeugung von b mesonen in gigantisch
großer zahl
diese können dies könnte durch
teilchenkollisionen im
teilchenbeschleuniger zb in japan
klappen daher gerade erst ernorm
aufgerüstet wurde auch in sachen
neutrinos könnte da ein entscheidender
erfolg kurz bevor stehen doch auch hier
reicht die datenlage jedoch derzeit noch
nicht aus um weitere subatomare prozesse
nachzuweisen bei denen die materie
überlegen ist auf eine finale theorie
zum materie antimaterie ungleichgewicht
müssen wir also offensichtlich noch
einige zeit warten
antimaterie schauer in hurrikan gefunden
draufklicken auf dieses video und
staunen bis dann bleibt dran